JAZYMN BLACKBURN: I'm interested
in sociology because I'm
interested in animal behavior.
I've always studied animal
behavior on my own growing up,
and then I became interested
in people behavior.
So, I'm interested
in studying sociology
so I can understand society as
a working ecosystem of people.
I'm Jazmyn Blackburn,
I'm in the Class of 2019,
I'm studying sociology.
My academics do really do
supplement my service work
in really interesting ways.
So, I do pursue classes
that I feel align
with my philosophy in education.
I want to be able to educate
the next generation of youth
to help them find their place.
Princeton Nursery School is a
community partner with the Pace
Center through Community House.
Since my freshman year, I've
been involved as a volunteer
and then I became
the project leader
for the Princeton Nursery School
Program and the connection
with the University.
So I bring volunteers,
I recruit volunteers,
get them engaged
in the community,
help support parents and
teachers in bringing up
these really amazing children
that go to the nursery school,
and that's a project
that I hope to continue
for the rest of my
time at Princeton.
See all-- so all the
black is the water, right?
That's a lot of water, and
then all the white is the land.
I think that early
childhood is definitely
a very influential time
in a person's life.
But, what I really
treasure about working
with young children is that
they have this capacity to them
to learn just about anything.
And they have their
whole life really
to fulfill who they're
going to become.
It's really an
incredible feeling
when you see a child
very early on who
has very primary
perceptions of the world
and just being able
to build on those
throughout their entire life.
Does it make a sound?
CHILD: There's not enough land here.
JAZYMN BLACKBURN:
Not enough land yet.
My goal is really
to leave a legacy Princeton
for future project leaders
and the connection, the bond
between this community partner
and the Pace Center.
I think that it's
really important
that encounters of service
don't just happen and disappear,
but that they're perpetuated,
and honestly I'd
love to see some of the
children I worked with in five
or 10 years and
hear their stories
and hear how they're doing.